[Musica]
saluto tutti è un grande piacere essere
qui con voi e ringrazio che ha
organizzato questo importante dette
soprattutto per avervi dato un tema qui
e ora che è un tema che ne ha fatto
molto riflettere ed eva fondamentale per
i tempi di oggi perché c'è questa
possibilità di collegarsi connettersi
con due parti del mondo con qualunque
individuo in qualsiasi angolo del mondo
ma ci ritroviamo soli ci ritroviamo
deboli specialmente dopo la galleria ci
ritroviamo con
lettura di regole e noi non abbiamo una
regola morale qui che davvero grazie per
avermi invitato a riflettere qui ed ora
quindi per me associando la mia
valigetta di attrezzi quindi io sono una
giurista ha fatto ricorso in campo le
materie diritto alla giustizia e salvo e
tutto questo le esperienze ho concluso
che qui ed ora è giunto bene si può
definire un dovere fondamentale
dell'uomo si parla sempre dei diritti
umani che sono i diritti fondamentali
della persona che sono ogni persona è
titolare perché persona perché essere
umano e non si parla di dover quindi c'è
oggi questa esigenza pressante di
parlare di doveri umani doveri
fondamentali della persona e io ritengo
che qui ed ora sia uno di questi doveri
fondamentali e dell'on
un commando morale molto imperativo e
ricchi di roma non si creano quel legge
che questa è una caratteristica sono
inerenti adesso ma e quindi anche i
doveri solitamente ma noi abbiamo
bisogno che qualcuno ci ordini di
ciliegie una regola per concludere che
qui ed ora sia sia un dovere
fondamentale dell'uomo è un comando
morale imperativo che ci consente di
guardarci meglio con più profondità
realtà che ci circonda che ci fa
responsabili di
responsabili di agire in maniera che la
dignità dell'essere umano sia
salvaguardato in qualsiasi condizione è
che sia l'essere umano custode
dell'ambiente in cui si trovano ovunque
come ci sono i diritti umani e quindi
atti doveri umani sono universali quindi
non ci sono limiti geografici in cultura
di lingua o di razza o anche limiti che
potrebbero ostacolare comunque farci
sentire
sollevati da queste responsabilità e per
me è il comando operativo da quando
avevo 13 anni perché io sono nata in
basilicata e quindi in un epoca dopo la
seconda guerra mondiale in epoche molto
molto molto difficile in un paesino
molto remoti molto lontani dai centri è
molto più vicino a dalian dove carolei è
stato confinato e che ha descritto
questa realtà è stata descritta sia nel
libro cristo si è fermato ad eboli sia
nei suoi dipinti molto importanti di
questo è uno di questi e ritrae ritrae
la condizione femminile in quei tempi a
basilicata quindi dove sono nate dopo
trascorsi i primi tredici anni quindi un
invito pressante ad agire a fare
qualcosa perché questa questo territorio
questa area così abbandonato trascurata
anche dalle istituzioni potesse
raggiungere uno standard minimo di
giustizia e dignità qui da pensato
subito che dovevo fare il magistrato
quindi dedicati alla giustizia cosa che
non è stato facile ma ci sono riuscito e
ho esercitato questa funzione in italia
per molti anni fino alla corte d'appello
di milano e poi sono
riuscite ad andare a lavorare come
magistra internazionale al tribunale
penale internazionale dell'ong per e jim
c del roanne quindi ho svolto funzioni
di procuratore e dopo però il magistrato
alla corte penale internazionale
è poi diretto la l'organo registri della
corte nel momento in cui ha avuto anche
fortuna perché sono arrivate queste
istituzioni internazionali le gomme che
in cui si sperimentavano questi norme
che mismi di giustizia e
troppi erano noi vedevamo nel 94 su
televisione nella bici preta on immagini
ci riportavano le notizie di cosa stava
succedendo a roma si stava a guardare e
era troppo grave era troppo grave quello
che stava succedendo per non lasciare la
corte d'appello di milano che questo era
un comando che per me si impone e andare
a fare questo lavoro di procuratore
quindi indagare vari processi
individuare i responsabili
i crimini atroci genocidio crimine con
domani tar crimini di guerra e formulare
accuse falli come mai quindi ho visto ho
visto e lo offro come spunto di
riflessione perché queste immagini
ritraggono dei resti di persona la linea
di morandi all'interno di scuole quindi
le scuole questo questi luoghi che
dovevano essere affollati di studenti
sono oggi che i resti di persone vittime
di genocida nell'aprile 1994 sono
migliaia e miglia in queste scuole e
questo si è detto si poteva evitare che
questo è che dobbiamo chiederci tutti
cosa possiamo evitare oggi ci sono altri
genocidi che potrebbe evitare altri
crimini di guerra che potremmo evitare
altri crimini contro umanita che
potremmo evitare un genocidio colma
scelto un genocidio atroce tanti altri
che si stanno un commento è il proprio
in quell occasione della visita morabito
incontrai ero molto scoraggiato
incontrai una bambina che usciva così
per caso in un capivo cosa volevano leva
chiedere a me qualcosa perché vedeva le
stime della wind poteva aiutarla voleva
studiare studiare questo mi ha dato una
carica enorme
e ho continuato il mio lavoro anche se
era molto scoraggiato quel giorno
abbiamo fatto molti processi abbiamo
individuato i responsabili tanto i nomi
ai criminali e alle vittime questo già
una forma di riparazione ma non bastava
una forma di liberazione di questo
genere quindi si è
stato un cambiamento rivoluzionario
nella giustizia penale internazionale
con l'introduzione della corte penale
internazionale che finalmente
riconoscere le vittime un ruolo
riconosce le vittime del diritto di
partecipare ai processi di
richiedere riparazione di essere
protetti quindi lo statuto di roma la
cui redazione ho avuto l'onore di
partecipare il 17 luglio
1998 ha lanciato quest'anno è grande
come dicevo rivoluzionare di rendere
giustizia alle vittime ed è un sistema
molto complicato quello delle vittime
che abbiamo di cui abbiamo consistito
arrow darci quel primo processo che
riguardava un crimine di guerra
l'arruolamento di minori di età
inferiore ai 15 anni ma in questo
periodo in questo mio periodo vedevo che
la corte con sede all'aja troppo lontano
dalle popolazioni tribali per i quali la
corte lavora e quindi nella mia agenda
opposto immediatamente né delle azioni
di andare sul se nei luoghi quindi
vicino alle popolazioni rubare loro
condizione e vedere qualche tipo di
intervento di riparazione forse più
appropriato qui ero a negli turi quindi
nel lodo questi crimini del primo
processo ma anche la corte si sono
commessi erano
poi ovviamente in altre situazioni
queste sono rifugiati che in ciad vi
vengono dal sud sudan perché come sapete
che è stata anche una terribile
lega con massacri
strumen i genocidi stupri violentissimi
approcci e di solito in questi luoghi
che siamo sempre nei campi di rifugiati
di regine più brevi ci sono moltissime
donne che chiedono insistentemente
giustizia questa donna tutto il tratto
si è alzato e si è posta verso di me con
un assist insistente insistente domanda
di giustizia perché la corte non fa
abbastanza presto proprio in una stanza
molto pressante il monumento di
sofferenza che si poneva da me altre
donne a sighet che siamo nella
repubblica centrafricana ancora donne
che chiedono insistentemente che la
corte faccia presto e agisca presto e
concretizzi verso la missione però e le
vittime quindi sono diventati il cuore
della giustizia penale internazionale
con una
evoluzione proprio della giustizia che
si occupa dei criminali ma si deve
occupare delle vicine e questo primo
processo che sta che si è tenuto al
posto di unità nazionale che ricordava
con detto e crimini di guerra è stato
per me ha marcato per me il futuro della
mia vita si può dire perché non potevo
non occuparmi del problema dei primi
risultati di queste scene che vedete in
queste foto che vedete sono state
riprese a kinshasa si tratta di un asilo
dove vengono ammucchiati i bambini che
sono che vengono nascono da stupide che
soddisfano le bambine su tap queste
bambine che poi rivendono duo ultimi non
e colico rifiutano assolutamente questi
bambini che vengono poi in queste
situazioni estreme e di sofferenze ci
sono albini che riescono a fuggire
sfuggire da questo dramma ma c'è molto
da fare bisogna
aiutarli e sono molto riconoscente a san
marino che ospita la convezione sui
bambini soldato sono ritengo che questo
qui a san marino e ora dobbiamo
assolutamente
riconoscere che questa azione sia
un'azione da fare nei tempi giusti da
fare e con con il l'impegno dovuto la
fondazione aggiunge alcuni di questi
bambini non tutti e quindi bisogna fare
di più e continuare e questo
invito fare meglio e di più
l'ho trovato nelle lettere nei disegni
dei bambini di san marino bis giovani
studenti della scuola media inferiore di
san marino che sono stati invitati a
scrivere lettere e bambini soldato della
regione dei grandi laghi africani e fare
dei disegni e in una di queste lettera
tra le altre cose e spero che queste
lettere verranno pubblicate perché
meritano potete leggere mai in una
lettera che quella che ha avuto il primo
premio tra le altre cose
interessantissime c'è anche questa frase
che mi ha colpito e posso assicurarti
quindi veronica scrive questo posso
assicurare al bambino soldato posso
assicurarti che se riesce a resistere a
tutto quello che stai passando in questo
momento quindi nei campi militari
sfruttati schiavi e cena alla tua età
può fare tutto quello che vuole e quel
senso della fiducia in se stessa che
questa domandina per noi della terza
media inferiore dice a un bambino
soldato quindi fiducia in te stessa e il
disegno che è stato fatto da un altro
studente è un po
dato la stessa lo stesso senso la stessa
comunicazione perché come vedete mette
una corona di regina ha una bambina
soldato quindi riesce se ha superato
tutte queste sofferenze riuscirà a fare
quello che va quindi dominerà il mondo
questo è penso che veronica e ci abbia
dato una chiave di come oggi dobbiamo
comportarci se riusciamo a sopportare
quello che stiamo supportando noi noi
magari meno di altri però come esseri
umani quello che stiamo soprattutto
possiamo fare quello che vogliamo e
questa fiducia in noi stessi deve essere
lo strumento essenziale perchè questo
dovere fondamentale che abbiamo un
dovere fondamentale una responsabilità
di ogni individuo ore non ci sono alibi
oggi proprio perché ci sono mezzi che lo
permettono con mezzi tecnologici e con
altri mezzi possiamo raggiungere
chiunque ovunque e dovunque quindi
dobbiamo agire
qui
senza ritardo ora perché il nostro
dovere casa
[Musica]